so it's been called the final frontier
space that is and we're hoping that dr
joseph borg takes us where no speaker
has gone before in this case
space omics joseph is an academic
molecular geneticist and the principal
investigator at the university of malta
primary interest is the understanding of
developmental globin gene switching
regulation and control of uracil
properties i'm not even going to try to
do that one again i'll let you correct
me on that and the next generation
sequencing tools to uncover locked
secrets of life he recently led malta's
first space program for life science in
space
through the maltest program and he also
actively participates
in the analysis working group at the
nasa gene lab for multi-omics and on the
topical team for european space agency
space omix
joseph my apologies for the star trek
introduction i'm sure i'm the first
person that's ever connected your name
with that right
yeah indeed indeed
do you hear me correctly i hope you do i
can hear you just fine and if you want
to go ahead and go to slideshow mode i'm
gonna get out of your way it's all yours
so thanks so much uh to the organizers
for for the invitation which i gladly
accepted and i feel really hard to say
honored to be part uh of this of this
omics research symposium because indeed
omics is one aspect of my research work
that i really enjoy doing
so yes so so so background aside
uh focusing on blood research and blood
omix today i'm talking to you about
malet program which is a life science
research program in space
and this is centered around
diabetes type 2 with special interest on
human skin microbiomes skin microbiomes
that are found on diabetic food ulcers
and i will explain uh why we study these
in the context of space
on earth and how we compare the two uh
with each other
so as a brief uh intro
let me just minimize the view screen
yeah so so all of this the research
program the mallet program started at
the end of 2020 so during the pandemic
years here in malta i had an idea
to sort of conduct or take my next level
of comic science in the context of space
it all came about serendipitously over
the internet over linkedin
having the idea and then meeting meeting
a group of people that can actually
bring the idea uh to fruition and at
that time i had i had uh
taken the idea to our ministry of
foreign and international affairs the
idea being that that sending an
experiment to space could not be more
foreign or more international than this
the idea was uh well received
and from there basically we we we
continued forward with our program so a
very quick quick rough shot about the
program so we did a number of pilot
studies in our labs
on earth in malta to ensure that the
human skin tissue samples the way they
are preserved the way they are prepared
in buffer that the bacteria the whole
microbiome is maintained for a number of
weeks or months and they do not lose
their viability and that we are able to
both culture them back on agar plates
and also we are able to extract dna and
tested by by ngs mostly 16s typing to
determine the classification and the
taxonomy of the bacteria
this project ties in very strongly with
an ongoing phd program of my student who
is testing roughly 150 or 200 diabetic
patients from malta so we only had a
selective number
of patients that we also progressed to
to the space study
uh this work was done in malta and also
in belgium where we assemble our
so-called biocube i will show this later
on
uh basically the cube itself
is shipped from europe to the states
from cape canaveral there it is
assembled on a spacex rocket spacex as
some of you or most of you know
travels to outer space and in this case
docks with the space station once it is
present or docked with the space station
the astronauts get to work they take out
the cube they assemble it to a
particular place where the cube is
powered up and from here from malta from
our control room or center we are able
to connect to the cube and follow the
experiment so to say
broadly speaking the experiment per se
is not too exciting to monitor because i
mean the bacteria and the skin tissue
don't really change microscopically or
visually except that you see everything
uh floating around but the real work is
done when the cube is returned back that
is what we did for mallet one and for
malet 2 which is a follow-up and a
replica because as as all of you know in
science you cannot really depend on one
experiment and biological replicates but
you also need to validate your findings
and that is mallet 2 and mallet 2 is
right now on its way from orlando to
europe and on its way back to malta this
very week or the end of this week so
it's an exciting time as well
okay yeah so so so of course all of this
all of this
precisely fits in the context of spots
of science uh i formed part of nasa gene
lab as one of the working groups also
essa european space agency also has its
own space omics team and basically in a
nutshell what what these groups are is
the experiments that we send to space
and back whether they are animal models
whether they are bacteria whether they
are plant or humans astronauts
the the biochemical and genetic data
that we get back are deposited in these
databases especially the nasa gene lab
gene lab repository and there the data
is part forms part of open science and
we call this open science for life in
space
we published a white paper a while ago
where it sort of uh drives the message
home about how we can take space biology
to the next era by ensuring
standardization applicability and also a
number of important tissue
analysis and fixation protocols we did
already have a number of scientific
publications on this topic not
necessarily on mallet but it also feeds
indirectly and these fall fall under the
the cell press
umbrella
so it is an area it is a topic where it
is very well sought also for publication
purposes so this is mallet one this is
the first cube of last year there's a 3d
printed cube using special special
plastic those are the logos and what is
okay what is mallet one basically so
marlette one as i said it centers around
diabetes diabetes as you know is a major
public health concern worldwide and
malta the country that i live in
is one of the highest prevalent in
europe actually about 12 percent of the
population is affected
a large number of diabetic patients are
at risk of developing food ulcers which
is a major cause of concern for
hospitalization
there are different types of science
symptoms
generally the people okay
a major problem is that they do not
speak up and therefore the infection and
the wound ulcers tend to become more
serious by time
the infections are polar microbial so
you cannot pin down one particular
microorganism
and a large number okay almost half or
more of these infections result in
osteomyelitis and also amputation
in the malta alone in the malta in one
year there are 400 cases of minor two
major amputations so more than one
person per year per day uh which is a
very very significant number so so this
this was the idea behind a phd study
which is ongoing and also the idea to
marry this together with the space
science research
this is a very conservative diabetic
food ulcer generally they are much worse
much bigger and yes here i would like to
mention
my phd student christine gutt was a
biomed scientist she works in a
laboratory at our hospital and she's
conducting her phd work at the
university and she's studying the
genetics of bacteria that infect wound
ulcers like christine i have a team of
at least
three other students who are one is also
doing a phd focusing on ophthalmic
disorders and two masters projects which
are focusing on global engine switching
and developmental control of hemoglobin
so so so the way that we work as a team
together even though the students are
not all on the same topic we share the
experience we discuss with each other
even in terms of general clubs and
generally this this this yields a
rewarding and a rich experience
so this is a typical look inside the
biocube you can see half of the cube on
the right hand side
is focused with with a raspberry pi and
computer essentials or accessories and
on the left hand side is the unit with
our cuvettes ready to be assembled with
the skin tissue sample itself
something small aside i am a strong
believer of training and inspiring the
young generation and so since
in the biocube we had space okay space
space and space we had an sd card that
can be
uh utilized to embed
uh messages or or artwork from school
children we did this we invited school
children from malta to have or to draw
something that has to do with climate
change global warming or send a message
to the world and we embedded all of
these files inside the cube in such a
way that we can open them when they are
in space and stream them or show them on
social media back on earth and this was
a this was a a nice exercise and we
could see that the young children were
really enticed
so this is just just just two two quick
pictures about the sample preparation
and on the right hand side you can see
the samples being integrated and this is
a more closer look
at the human skin tissue samples
and how they are placed in each cuvette
okay of course the biocube is one part
of the experiment on the other side of
the story that is
on earth and in malta we also require a
laptop or a mission control room where
we can plug in
our system and we are able to
communicate or contact directly the
biocube itself
for many reasons some of which are for
aesthetic or fun
the use of camera to see the samples to
ensure that there were no major
breakages or problems
there are also a number of sensors to
detect the temperature humidity and one
can adjust those store sensors and there
is also led lighting and that you can
change different colors according to the
moods that one is feeling
but basically basically having a mission
control center back on earth
ensures peace of mind that the
experiment is going well
this is the cube itself positioned on a
module which is an exact replica that is
found on board the columbus module on
the space station okay ice cube stands
for international commercial experiment
and you will see one of these also
onboard the space station later on this
is the cube in its final steps with all
the samples integrated packaged in a
special box and shipped to the states
and from the states as i said the
astronaut handled the cube and you can
see here
playing station until the escape
activities are complete
and i'll look before further conference
we are very much grateful for your
support today we also took note of your
japan skills so thanks for the
entertainment and then the crook these
every conference is ready on space to
ground forward
so there's just some talk between the
astronauts and mission controls
that's when they mentioned malta for the
first time
and there there you can see our cube
alongside others
placed on board the ice cubes facility
which is located on board the space
station once plugged that is powered up
and we have access to it uh from earth
once once
roughly between 30 35 days elapse
the same
spacecraft that took the experiment to
the space station
is undocked it deorbits around the earth
and falls or splashes down in the
atlantic ocean
there a boat will go out it will
retrieve the spacecraft the spacecraft
is taken back to the kennedy space
center and from there all the
experiments that were sent from the
space station back to earth are sorted
it's just like a post in service and we
receive the the cube back to malta and
there where the real work starts where
we open up the cube we we take out audi
samples and there is a battery of tests
that we do on all these skin tissue
samples which includes aerobic
and anaerobic bacteria the use of
cultural media as broth and also
cultural media as aegar's and various
forms of course christine god being the
microbiologist is much more well-versed
in all the different tests that we do
uh an interesting observation or a
photograph that we had to do was when we
identified that bacteria sent to space
and back were actually cultivated on
agar blades so this showed us for the
first time for us in malta that we are
we were able to send an experiment the
bacteria and the skin microbiome
survived and came back to earth to sort
of tell tell detail
yes so
there is there is a large number of
genetics and omic tools that we are
doing
the first of which which is concluded is
a first wave analysis which we call a
16s typing and 16s typing serves as a
taxonomy
classification of all the bacteria that
are present in in these samples in the
mallet one we had six different samples
so
six different patients that came to our
hospital and each patient a human skin
tissue sample was obtained
the human skin tissue sample as part of
the surgery process was split in three
okay
one was immediately processed and frozen
so we obtained the human skin microbiome
profile on day one
and the other two
pieces
one was left in our lab on earth and one
was sent to space and back and therefore
for each single patient which we have
six okay we have three different
data points as you like okay so we have
the omics or the 16s typing for each
of the three
uh timelines and we can compare the
differences between those three
and we can also compare the differences
between the six samples with each other
okay and they're where we obtain a
comparative a comparative genomics
approach
um this this figure shows you a spread
and and the largest number of bacteria
found together with the lowest number of
bacteria found in the skin sample itself
of course this was replicated for all
samples
yeah so so so our aim was to obtain a
signature that is correlated with the
tissue type itself we had many other
tissue types as well i mean we had a
simple skin swab from healthy controls
to act as a control we had the foot
ulcers themselves those which were sent
to space station and those which sent
which were uh left or on earth we also
had biofilms from certain wound ulcers
and we also had negative uninoculated
controls
there is extensive informatics that was
done i did not do this myself but a team
of bioinformaticians also with the help
at nasa gene lab which exclusively work
on these type of analyses
and interestingly from these analyses
uh before going into metagenomic
sequencing which is being conducted as
we speak so to say which we are waiting
for for the mallet two samples as well
but from just the 16s typing we could
see or we could observe that a small
select number of bacterial species
in space
appear to thrive or flourish more
than the ones than the same tissue type
that was left on earth so there are
these
subtle differences but meaningful
between one tissue type of one patient
left on earth sent to space and the
differences between the two and we have
a select number of bacteria that exhibit
these differences
like i mentioned that
later on one of which one key bacteria
is more vanilla
morganae
yes also so the immediate next steps is
that we are comparing the 16s data
between these three data points over the
six biological replicates
something which we haven't done yet
but we want to explore is that the
patients themselves who came to hospital
we will also be
sequencing the full genome of each of
each patient and this we believe will
give added data added information that
we can sort of
interplay or overlay so to say the
genomic data of the patient together
with the microbiome data obtained from
the human skin
metagenomic sequencing is a no-brainer
so that is being done on the isolated
microbiome together with colleagues
in the states and of course there are a
number of key people that sort of
what i have shown or presented in these
few slides have made this possible so
primarily there is the ministry for
foreign european affairs and for malet 2
there is also the ministry now for
research and innovation
a number of key people that are in the
states and these are chris mason he's a
very renowned scientist who in the past
has worked on
nasa
twin astronauts maybe some of you know
mark and scott kelly who are one of them
is a senator
uh they are twins they are identical
twins they are both astronauts and there
was a huge study where one of the twins
was on earth the other twin was a year
in space and therefore there are many
blood samples being taken urine samples
and other measurements and one can can
conduct all the genomics and the
multi-omics that one can think of and
compare between the two and it's amazing
the results that one gets back brayden
brayden tierney is the one who conducted
the informatics for the mallet program
after was the original point of contact
at nasa who introduced me to the world
of space bioscience i am individual to
him
kevin kasarin team he is a vascular
surgeon at our hospital and he's the one
who physically operates and takes the
skin tissue i mean we depend on these
medical professionals
arka fort and evolve are private tech
companies it's impressive
the the the interest that we see in such
experiments or programs by the private
sector who want to be part of this
mission
also an interesting and interesting uh
bartering idea as if you like is that
the biotech companies that agree to
sponsor our work or sponsor our mission
they get to emblazon their logo on the
cube itself so that is that is
uh
exposure that is out of this world in
the literal sense of the world
and of course christine got this she's
the phd she's the phd candidate who's
doing all of the groundwork in the lab
physically working
yeah so this slide is we're almost at
the end here the slide is sort of a
collection of mallet one which is the
top left cube
and the mallet two which is the bottom
left cube
you can see a color change
uh malet 2 is an improvement on the cube
design it is made up of a machined
aluminum so this is like the same as a
macbook laptop or these new fancy
laptops that are made of aluminium and
basically you have a block of aluminium
and they are machined from the inside to
outside
and there was also an upgrade of the
raspberry pi computer itself and there
on on the bottom on the center bottom
you can see a usb dongle a key that is
used to connect directly with the iss
an interesting idea or notion is that
once you plug in this dongle okay
automatically the mission control room
or the laptop that you're using
disconnects with the internet and you
only connect with the iss this is part
of the encryption and security security
policy
and on the far right far right there you
can see the spacex rocket that departed
earth
to arrive to the iss
this is a list of all
sponsors and logos to date
and three pictures that shows you a
close image of malasta cube
yes mylettes2 i didn't speak too much
about this
we had five samples and not six
microbiomes and we had one sample
reserved for dried yeast saccharomyces
cerevisiae we have some ideas that we
wish to to implement
when the experiment gets back
and that's the cube itself on board
the platform itself
and i believe that was the last slide
and if you have any questions or ideas
or maybe you have an idea to send to
space feel free to reach out to me on
joseph spaceomics.com
and watch out for for some emerging
publications on a mallet so with that
i thank you all for being patient to
listen to me
i think i cannot hear your grunts i
cannot hear you
good old microphone
does gravity play a role this is from
the audience does gravity play a role on
aging process and the rate of cell
division i'm assuming he means in space
so in gravity
does gravity play a role
so so there are some conflicting of
course this is this is a little bit
different from the mileage program that
we do right however in the context of
aging
we have been
told
that that in space we age faster
however recent recent evidence and is
also published
there seems to be
observation that telomeres
at the end of the chromosomes instead of
shortening
actually
in longer duration they elongate and
that means that the cells might actually
become more
younger
so maybe we'll be having trips to space
to become younger as opposed to aging
well that'd be interesting a little
expensive but interesting nonetheless
right
so
how was the malice program used to
understand living in space
yeah so so so mallet program okay so so
it's ambitious it's a very first program
for malta and the the idea or the
overall objective besides the core is a
life science experiment on diabetes type
2. we also know that
astronauts in space generally are very
healthy and and and athletic okay
however astronauts in space also have
difficulties with with vascularization
and the bloodstream itself they undo
space anemia
so understanding uh wound ulcers food
ulcers and the complications that arise
on earth
can feed indirectly with complications
that we observe in space especially if
space is opened up wider for astronauts
who might not be completely athletic or
fit
like some of the people that can just
pay to get there right
so do you think there are specific
measures that astronauts take before or
after going into space maybe talk about
one or two of them
this is this is a very very good
question i think to date it is still not
completely set in stone but there are
definite measurements i mean any
measurements that are done
at the brain eeg and cardiac cardiac
function i mean these these are these
are these are
logical tests that need to be done to
assert that the individual the astronaut
is fit
especially to survive a three-month
six-month mission
an interesting thing is the introduction
of omics testing genomics dna rna
expression profiling this is a very very
very recent entry and as we progress
we're going to see more and more omics
testing on astronauts
fascinating
well thank you yet again this has been
wonderful i apologize again on all the
star trek references but that was fun
glad you played along you're welcome
[Music]
you